welcome back to you please welcome our
sense anything called The Hip Hop Howard
Stern Charlemagne the God it's one of
the most influential voices in the
American Media right now with a smashing
show and a very influential
predominantly black audience Harry is in
action
what is it about music that you love so
much that would still make you want to
go on the damn radio grind because you
don't need it you're rich you're famous
you don't need to be on this radiograph
I love I love music put your hands in
there
I'm singing This is how we're living
down here sitting on the edge looking
out without disorder if you don't mind
you know what I had a really strong
voice like exceptionally he's a strong
voice hello it was 46 years old and they
do mention your husband a lot and he
said how is she's so black when she
married white you got more questions but
I tell you if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're familiar
Trump and you ain't black
well Charlemagne joins me now
Charlemagne it's great to have you on
uncensored thank you very much indeed
for finally uh securities
thank you thank you for having me how
are you I don't really fast at anybody
because we come from very different
backgrounds upbringings I was always
wanted to be a journalist I trained to
be a journalist I went to a English
journalism college and worked my way up
and I do a lot of interviews you came
from a very different background in
South Carolina nothing about that
background suggested that you would end
up being one of the most influential
interviewers in American Media how do
you think that's happened
I think that's happened because
um you know I'm I'm I always approach
things from the perspective of just a
curious fan you know I always feel like
the know-it-all knows nothing and you
know I'm not an expert at anything I'm
just the person who you know has some
experiences in life and you know my
mother was an English teacher in South
Carolina and you know one of the things
that she told me when I was younger was
to always read things that you know uh
don't necessarily pertain to you so
being that she told me that I always had
this curiosity for a little bit of
everything so I would read everything
from you know the double XL magazine to
you know every Judy Bloom book in the
library and I think just having that you
know curiosity and always approaching
things from the perspective of a curious
fan you know I think that might be that
might be intriguing to some people it's
very intriguing a whole story is very
intriguing to me uh you were born
Leonard Larry McKelvey and I'm a big
Bernard Leonard I gotta correct you from
I'm sorry
you'd be called Leonard over here
um but what's interesting about you is
I'm a big believer in second chances for
people God knows I've had enough of them
myself in my career
um but you in your early years you got
into a bit of trouble you were arrested
twice for possession of drugs on your
third arrest uh because you were near a
non-fatal shooting at the time uh your
father refused to pay bail money and you
went to jail and after 41 days you asked
your mother to pay for the bill and that
point your father decided to give you
another chance how when you look back on
it how pivotal was that moment of your
father deciding I'm going to give him
another another go at this and see what
happens
man that was um that was very pivotal
you know and and honestly it wasn't a it
wasn't it wasn't something that I I took
it serious as I should because you know
I kind of went back you know to to
hanging around the same crowd and you
know being involved in a lot of the same
you know type of activities but it was
very it was very pivotal for me you know
because my father used to always tell me
something he would always say man if you
don't change your lifestyle you're going
to end up in jail dead or broke sitting
under the tree and you know when you're
that age and you start to see people
around you actually go you know the the
prison for for long stint so you saw
people around you actually dying or you
saw people that you used to look up to
you know actually be broke sitting under
the tree and you know you can kind of
see yourself going down that same path
it kind of like is a wake-up call you
like yo my father is right so that for
me that was one of those you know
moments that just made me say I do have
to to change my lifestyle because I
truly believe that destiny is not a a
matter of chance it's a matter of choice
and you know I think a lot of us we just
make you know poor choices for for
whatever reason so you know I just think
you know you make you make you make
better choices you better the chances of
uh you know having having a more
successful life I completely agree now
takes it takes a healthy ego let me put
it like that to rename yourself the god
why did you do that
um because I studied I grew up studying
the five percent teachers you know and
in the five percent teachers they teach
you that uh God is a Greek word derived
from the Arabic Words gumar azabar which
means wisdom script and Beauty in the
first letter of each word was used by
Greek students and their identification
of their you know Egyptian teachers so
that's one thing and then in the Bible
it says God created Man In His Image
according to his likeness so you know
whenever somebody literally said this to
me uh yesterday when I was doing
something unhealthy which is reading the
comments on social media and they said
your name is derived from ego and I said
no actually my name is derived from uh
five percent teachings in in scripture
very interesting and that Biden clip
that we had at the end there let's move
to the the general political scene in
America right now Biden's claim there in
that interview that if basically if
you're a black person in America you
should be voting for him
um let's just replay that again just to
remind viewers of this
you got more questions but I tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black
now what did you make of that when he
said that what was your instinctive
reaction
my instinctive reaction was exactly what
I said in that moment like you know it's
not about Trump it's just about me you
know wanting to you know get something
for my community you know votes are
transactional you know we vote for you
um you do something for us and so that's
literally where my mind was at and and
you know even with that you know you
ain't black comment that he made you
know I think he got that from black
people that were around him at the time
and I think that was a a Granddad joke
but I I I think what he was trying to
say is simply you know if you vote for
Donald Trump as a black person you may
be voting against your own interests and
what do you think about that
as far as what do I think about what
about what you just said about what
people may have thought by meant do you
think that is true do you think you're
voting against your own interests as a
black American if you've overdrum
yes I do because you know I feel like
you know Donald Trump is a a threat to
democracy and um you know when you talk
about a country that could be leaning
toward fascism because you have people
in a party that are leaning toward
fascism you know as a black person or
any minority I don't think you know you
would want to live under a fascist
regime and you know that's not something
that you know it doesn't matter what
your money how much money you have or
you know what your status is you know if
you're a person of color or a minority
under a fascist regime regime I don't
think that's going to fail too well for
you the problem at the moment it seems
for people who share your views about
that there are many Americans who share
uh that opinion of trump and there are
many who still support him is that Trump
is running away with the Republican
nomination race fueled it seems by all
these legal issues that he has the more
times he gets indicted we're up to
nearly 100 criminal charges now the more
popular he seems to get and part of that
is people thinking it's the
establishment trying to destroy him and
people don't like that in America even
if they don't agree necessarily with
Trump's political views they just think
he's getting put upon and victimized is
all this backfiring do you think just as
a as a reality check about the political
environment
I kind of expected this like you know I
knew that it was an easy call for him uh
to say that it's gonna it's a Witch Hunt
you know I I kind of I kind of predicted
that you know if he was listening to you
know my radio show The Breakfast Club on
my podcast the brilliant idiots I was
saying that you know uh I I could see a
lot of this working in his favor now I
don't know how it's going to work in a
general election because I think you
have a lot of independent voters I don't
know if they'll necessarily you know uh
show up for him and you know those
hypothetical swing voters who you know
voted for President Obama one year and
then came back and voted for you know
Trump another year they might have came
back and you know voted for President
Biden I don't know if they're
necessarily going to show up but the
thing I find interesting about Trump
um president Trump the most is that um
you know you you have 91 criminal
charges uh what is it for for
indictments I haven't heard him talk
about policy at all I haven't heard him
talk about you know any legislation he
wants to implement at all every time
he's getting on television it's about
The Witch Hunt and it's about the
charges against him and to me man I
would have to look at the people who are
supporting him and say well what are
y'all supporting like because because
he's not even out there campaigning oh I
guess I mean the other the other side of
the coin is that Biden himself is now
looking horribly old and it's not about
his age it's just his ability to perform
to function I know you said a lot about
this yourself that you're very concerned
about this Nikki Haley wants to put term
limits now on age limits now on
politicians you're seeing it with Mitch
McConnell you're seeing it with Dianne
Feinstein you've seen Biden falling over
and stumbling and making mistakes
constantly it does seem an extraordinary
situation that America this incredible
multi-racial Multicultural uh place can
only come up at a 330 million people
with Joe Biden and Donald Trump one
already in his 80s one heading to his
80s one facing nearly 100 criminal
charges one can barely string a sentence
together how can it be that this is is
the only choice that might be presented
to the American people next year
man yeah you're absolutely right peers
and that's something that you know I
discuss a lot and people around me
discuss a lot but the only thing I can
tell people right now and I I I don't
belong to you know any particular party
but I will tell you that you have one
party who still seems like you know
they're they're they're attempting to
preserve democracy you know no matter
how old their leadership is and you have
some another party that seems like you
know they're on the fast track the
fascism so you just have to ask yourself
do you care about democracy or not as an
American you just have to ask yourself
that simple question do you care about
democracy or not if the answer is yes
then hey man you might have to vote for
the elderly
it's an extraordinarily disparaging
Choice uh Charlemagne it's great to talk
to you thank you thank you very much and
Dave for coming on the show I appreciate
it
thank you